for the second week in a row the TSA has
confiscated a record number of firearms
at security checkpoints at a bunch of US
airports 81 guns were seized between
August 12th and 18th and of the weapon
70 were loaded 31 actually were loaded
with a chambered round meaning that just
squeezing the trigger would have
discharged the firearm this brings the
number seized in 2016 from carry-on
baggage to over 1900 this is 400 more
weapons seized than at this point last
year usually the way it works is there's
a loaded gun in a carry-on bag or in a
purse tsa finds it and the excuse is I
forgot and Lois we've told the story
where you brought a knife on a plane
you also forgot however TSA did not
notice that knife that is true I
legitimately forgot and it was basically
because it was this multi-tool that
happened to have a big blade and it
wasn't just a combat knife but that's
the I forgot thing happens and I'm sure
many of these instances people actually
did forget listen to all the stories we
cover all the time that someone forgot
they had their hand that their hand gun
in their purse or somewhere in the car
and then there's an quote accident
there's some negligent act yeah I mean I
would consider I would consider that if
you are unaware of the location of your
loaded firearm right that if you forget
that that a loaded firearm is in your
purse what you're basically saying is
you've been entrusted with with
jurisdiction over this firearm and you
were unaware of the location of the
loaded firearm that to me is very very
concerning yeah it definitely is it's
also interesting because post 9/11 I
there was definitely heightened security
in airports and I remember when I was a
lot younger I tried to get through with
a nail clipper and I couldn't oh yeah
you could take down a plane with them
yeah
they actually confiscated it and then on
my most recent flight I got in with a
needle in my bag yet they confiscated
this much amount of water that sounds
like an interesting story actually that
we'll talk about that on the bonus show
so what what is the process when TSA
discovers that you have a firearm
basically that security checkpoint
completely shut down police are called
everybody else gets angry who's around
you and you face a criminal referral and
a fine of up to $11,000
I actually am really concerned about
this number one because I don't like the
idea of people bringing guns into
airports but I'm more concerned because
a recent test of the TSA where they went
in and tried to sneak banned items
through ninety-five percent of them got
through so in my head I'm thinking that
there are 19 guns getting through
security for every one that is being
caught is that crazy to think might be
going on not at all I mean I remember so
my two stories are when I was a kid I
went to Texas I brought m-80s on my
carry-on baggage into the plane and
brought them out at Massachusetts and
the other one was I flew from once from
Florida to Massachusetts you know
stopped off and then I got my kind of
similar to Lois got my Leatherman tool
onto the plane
kinda unbeknownst to me but then I took
a layover in San Francisco but the non
TSA there's different uh you know forces
a few airports that don't use TSA
essentially exactly but they caught me
and then I had to you know get it off to
somebody and you know get on my plane
flights and of course you could say
really well you know TSA let me on the
plane with this knife they're not
particularly successful there are two
reasons someone would be bringing a
unless you're truly ignorant of the fact
that you're not allowed to have guns on
planes which is very hard for me to
believe you either are trying to bring
the gun on the plane to use it on the
plane or to deliberately break a law in
which case you shouldn't be on the plane
or as I've said you've lost track of
where your firearm is Louis and both to
me would be reasons to keep somebody off
of a plane you yes but I don't think we
know anybody who is the type of person
we know people who owned plenty of guns
but they're not the people who leave
guns everywhere you walk into someone's
house and there's a gun on every stand
there's a gun in in the nightstand
there's a gun under the the couch yeah
these people exist they're everywhere in
the United States and I'm guessing a
great deal of the people that got caught
here this is exactly that type of person